welcome back to Las Vegas now thanks to
upside the sponsors of this segment
people are getting paid for making a
purchase Rocky shows us how you can live
on the upside too
let's head to the New Circle K on North
Simmons Street in North Las Vegas
where customers can come for gas food
fresh coffee and if they're using the
upside app cash back using the upside
app is a no-brainer this is Carlos a
local Rideshare driver using the upside
app to fill up his tank and his pocket I
feel like us
three times a week is a lot it's like
70 or 70 dollars each time so and I get
roughly like three to five dollars back
on each field
so it's been a great help after
living on the upside
user in the Las Vegas Valley and I saved
about 240 dollars
in cashback
I am according with the app one of the
in the top two percent users
and I use it in gas
and in my restaurant that I choose yep
restaurants are another way the upside
app helps you fill up a restaurant is
more than the gas it's about 12 in the
restaurant I choose usually using my gym
there's inside the restaurant I I buy my
smoothies my power drinks there and I
say I got a lot of money from there now
when it comes to restaurants the app
only works for dining in or picking up
takeout and guess what you can also get
cash back on alcohol okay Las Vegas try
not to spend it all on partying Carlos
has another idea I only use it with an
Amazon gift cards
whenever I have to buy something oh I
have a certificate there and I use it
simple the app shows you how much you
you have after your last cash out so you
can tap there and you can choose between
several options
including transfer to your bank or use
it as a gift card now that's something
to text the group chat about I post it
in
my friends chat and I got some of them
sign up and I believe they got seven
percent and by referring people you
increase your own earnings that's what
we call an upside
thank you to upside for sponsoring this
segment for more information visit
upside.com and don't forget about their
special offer news 25 to get extra 25
cents per gallon cash back on their
first fill up Las Vegas now we'll be
right